what up space fam goes in here from
anime opera back at it again to discuss
the latest craziest
and most hilarious developments in the
one punch man story the feedback on the
one punch man videos has been amazing so
far
and if you want to keep them coming you
know what to do smash that like button
and share this video with any heroes for
fun that you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future one punch man videos
as you wait for the next chapter or
video to drop feel free to check out my
growing one punch man playlist where i
got videos about the s-class heroes
blast
all dragon and god level monsters and
much more link in the description
also follow anime upper on twitch where
we'll be doing fun stuff like reacting
to one punch man chapters live
discussing the series enjoying some dank
one punch man memes
and just hanging out you can find the
link to the anime uproar twitch
in the description now without further
ado let's jump into it
i cover both the manga and the webcomic
of one punch man on this channel and
this video will be about the web comic
the web comic is ahead of the manga so
there will be some very juicy spoilers
in this video just so you know
so in my last webcomic review we talked
about blast
sun blue he is the founder and top hero
of the neo heroes at only 16 years old
the neo heroes isn't just a rival
organization to the hero association
the neo heroes are actually the favorite
of the two right now
in the public's eye the neo heroes are
having more and more success
and the hero association is having more
and more problems and we'll get more
into that as we move forward but first
let's turn to blue himself again
in the last video i was curious to see
how strong he'd be
he came across a disaster level dragon
monster and he knew he had to be careful
but he still seemed pretty confident
that he could beat it remember it
usually takes a strong
s-class hero to defeat a disaster level
dragon monster and it turns out that
blue could seemingly defeat the dragon
level monster
called eel dragon it wasn't a walk in
the park and blue is sweating bad
he even says that he just barely
defeated it and that it was scary
because he couldn't tell if his attacks
were working or not until it started
writhing in pain and eventually stopped
moving he also had to unlock
all of the suits limiters and so he
can't move the suit anymore
then blue does something pretty epic
when he hears that there's another
dragon level monster he straight up
breaks out of his suit which was a
pretty big flex
not gonna lie of course with powerful
suits being brought in
it makes you question how strong blue
would be without his customized suit but
it clearly seems like he's strong even
without it
he breaks out of it so he can move and
decides to go
to the other dragon level threat with no
suit that's very cool showing he
clearly has a lot of courage mccoy the
neo heroes executive
absolutely hates the idea not wanting
blast sun to risk his life and blue
knows why it's because then he
the son of blast couldn't be used for
marketing and that's one of the things
that the neo heroes do
really well they are amazing with pr and
marketing themselves as the better hero
organization
and we also get some pretty hype words
blue says that he became a hero in order
to surpass his father
so he can't just sit back and watch i
gotta admit this introduction of blast
sun
is one of the most interesting things to
me in the webcomic right now
and i get excited with every new detail
revealed about him and by extension
about blast as well
however we then jump scenes it's worth
mentioning that flashy flash tatsumaki
and jenos all defeated their dragon
level threats too but
flashy flash still let poisonous gas
spread throughout the city tatsumaki
couldn't stop her city from being
destroyed
and genos was very very beaten up after
his fight
while blue could keep fighting for
example jenos was out of commission for
the foreseeable future so despite the
fact that blue
had more trouble in his fight than
tatsumaki and flashy flash
his victory is arguably a bigger success
in the public eye
because he was better at containing the
damage we've also been following saitama
and the hero name
victims association a hilarious group
that continues to protest the terrible
hero names they were given
like caped baldy for example in
saitama's case
every part with these guys is hilarious
they come across
mirror a dragon level robot threat the
robot had no problems dealing with suiko
aka suiru's
younger sister saitama's fellow hero
named victims attack
see that they can't do anything and then
start retreating saitama thought they'd
show off their skills so their names
would be changed but when it comes down
to it they're pretty much
all cowards except of course saitama
saitama remains but the robot is
unimpressed it has statistics on a-class
heroes and s-class heroes
but is not interested in saitama because
everything about him sounds weak
he calls saitama caped baldy and tells
him to disappear
saitama gets so mad for being called
cape baldy that he angrily finishes a
dragon level threat with one punch
one member says as expected from the
leader of the hero name
victims association and then they all
high five this dynamic is the best it
really is
and blue actually witnessed what saitama
did here so along with the others he's
stunned at having witnessed something so
crazy coming from an a-class hero in the
following chapter tatsumaki goes on her
own mission to fight a group of 11
people called
11. fittingly enough they experimented
on kids in order to turn them into
espers probably on tatsumaki too in the
past so she decides to go deal with them
so obviously blast is out of the picture
as usual
now number two tatsumaki pieces out to
do her own thing and even flashy flash
goes on his own mission to fight the
group called abandoned masses
a group that's made it their life
ambition to cut down the human
population
and apparently they're really strong
because in the ninja village they were
told not to get involved with them
that's pretty crazy because the ninja
village was full of very strong people
but the point is
this puts flash out of the picture as
well and even he thinks
it will take no less than four or five
days to deal with this
as flashy flash is talking to the hero
association he tells them to try to
mobilize blast
if it bothers them that the neo heroes
are outclassing them so much and
mentions how blue a boy who calls
himself blast's son
is being treated as today's big savior
and this is what i was referring to
blue is in the people's minds right now
the number one hero
not just within the neo heroes but among
all heroes because he managed to come
out of a dragon level fight
unscathed while minimizing the
destruction as well i'm not saying he's
the strongest but the fact remains that
he's number one in the public's eye
right now
as the hero association mentions he's
become a beacon of hope for the people
even the hero name victims association
got praised as a separate organization
for dealing with dragon level threat
mirror but the world doesn't seem to
want the hero association anymore at all
we go on to learn that most s-class
heroes aren't really available right now
as we know some have already left to
join the neo heroes and in addition to
the three mentioned meaning tatsumaki
flashy flash
and genos who are currently unavailable
pig god's lack of mobility means they
can't rely on his cooperation
atomic samurai and his disciples are
away for their own personal training
regiment
in order to surpass their limits metal
knight is silent and seems like the main
villain at this point
and watchdog man one of my favorites
doesn't care about anywhere other than
his territory
which he's protecting very well and it's
causing the pricing to shoot through the
roof
and the list goes on it seems like drive
knight is the only available s-class
hero at this point
we go on to learn more about how the neo
heroes are actually very sketchy
they are making people undergo
cyborgification
thus making them stronger but also
seemingly
taking away people's free will and
turning them into mindless slaves
of their organization they are not just
doing this to people who get seriously
injured in battle though
they even tried to do it to now neo-hero
metal bat luckily the security guards
have tried to kill metal bats so he can
be revived as an obedient cyborg
are not strong or fast enough for him i
really like metal bat and the second
most recent chapter finishes with him
considering which neo-hero agent he'll
send to the hospital first
i'm just glad he has his bat on him as
usual so he can put up the best possible
fight
and that brings us to the latest chapter
of the webcomic we got a fight between
speedo sonic
and the neo heroes so in this case the
neo heroes forces consists of
a bunch of heroes in suits and a a
former criminal whose goal it is to kill
as many people as he can before he dies
i told you neo heroes are super sketchy
and of course you start to understand
why people like sonic don't like heroes
when they are willing to employ such
maniacs as a
along with flashy flash sonic recently
got a ninja scroll power boost
sonic takes down 29 men in suits with
his speed of sound electric discharge
fist and then after seeing he's
outclassed a runs away
in the meantime the hero name victims
association
continues to protest we learn that the
neo heroes refuse to work with the hero
association on equal terms
and even start directly challenging them
super sumo champion raiden
wants to take puri puri prisoners group
of criminals that he's trying to
rehabilitate
the new heroes want to cyborgify them so
that they'll be a completely controlled
workforce
and he even says that they have the
government's permission
bystanders also want the criminals off
the streets
but puri puri prisoner is prepared to
valiantly protect his men
so it seems like we're going to get a
raiden versus puri puri prisoner fight
soon which should be very hype all of a
sudden the hero association heroes are
being portrayed as the villains while
the sketchy neo heroes have public
approval
hilariously enough puripuri prisoner
warns raiden that he's into sumos too
and it's funny because every time
puripuri prisoner pops up like
it's guaranteed to make me laugh as
usual we can count on puri puri prisoner
for comedic gold
lastly if all that wasn't hype enough we
got
suiru who is a neo hero now and he's
apparently got the hero hunter
surrounded
so it seems like we'll get to see garo
soon too which is crazy to think about
let me know how you guys are liking the
webcomic right now
and how you like these last few chapters
like i said i've been loving the hero
name victim
stuff and also the info on blue blast
sun although blue seems pretty strong
with his hero suit
we have yet to see him push to his limit
saitama beat mirror before blue had a
chance to take him on
with no suit and it did seem kind of
weird to me that blue didn't know
if he was having any effect on the
dragon level monster until
it suddenly started moving around in
pain and stopped moving altogether could
it have been
an external force that suddenly defeated
the dragon level monster like the
computer chip that child
emperor found inside of it rather than
blue himself were the other dragon level
monsters also sent to cause damage
by the neo-heroes in order to make them
look even better
at this point the neo heroes are
definitely sus and i wouldn't be
surprised if it was all a setup
to make them look good and the hero
association looked bad
as we saw mccoy freaked out when blue
wanted to fight another dragon level
monster without his suit
he clearly doesn't have a lot of faith
in his power and primarily values blue
because of the name recognition he has
for being blast's son
as things stand right now blue is the
top hero in the public's eye
which is fitting for blast's own sun but
as we know in one punch man things
usually aren't how they appear to be
and we'll need to see more before we can
truly judge the power of blue
and that is it for this video thank you
so much for watching
if you enjoyed this video and want to
keep the one punch man videos coming you
know what to do
smash that like button really serious
punch it and share this video with any
heroes for fun that you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future one punch man videos
as you wait for the next chapter or
video to drop feel free to check out my
growing one punch man playlist where i
got videos about the s-class heroes
blast all dragon and god level monsters
and much more link in the description
also follow anime upload on twitch where
we'll be doing fun stuff like reacting
to one punch man chapters live
discussing the series enjoying some dank
one punch man memes
and also just hanging out together and
i'll put a link to the twitch in the
description as well
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you